what I have here are three numbers
plotted on the number line we have the
number a the number C the number B and
then we have three inequality of four
inequalities actually four inequalities
that involve absolute value and what I
want to do is figure out which of these
inequalities are true given where a C
and B are on the number line and I
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think through it on your own alright
let's look at this first one it says
that a is less than B so if we look at a
and we look at B a is clearly to the
left of B on the number line so we know
that this is this is true even more we
know that a is negative it's to the left
of zero while B is positive which is if
one thing is negative and the other
thing is positive the negative thing is
definitely going to be less than the
positive thing but even easier than that
a is to the left of B on the number line
if you're to the left of something else
on the number line you're less than that
other thing because then the number line
at least the way we've constructed it it
increases from left to right all right
the next statement the absolute value of
a is greater than the absolute value of
B let's just think about where these are
on the number line so we've already said
a is three hash marks to the left of
zero that is a so what is going to be
the absolute value of a well the
absolute value of a is the distance that
a is from zero so the distance that a is
from zero is one two three hash marks so
the absolute value of a is just going to
be that same distance on the positive
side so the point that we marked as C is
also the absolute value of a so that is
also the absolute value of a absolute
value of a I'm sorry a is three to the
left of zero absolute value of a is
going to be three to the right it's just
a measure of how how many hash marks is
it from zero what's three hash marks
from zero so we put it right over here
so is the absolute value of a greater
than the absolute value of B well what's
the absolute value of B well B is one
two
three four five six seven eight hash
marks to the right of zero and so the
absolute value of B is going to be on
the eighth hash mark because it's eight
hash marks to the right so this is also
the absolute value of B and this is
consistent with what we've learned about
absolute value absolute value of a
positive number it's just going to be
that number again absolute value of a
negative number is going to be the
opposite of that number an absolute
value of zero is just going to be zero
so is the absolute value of eight
greater than the absolute value of B
well no absolute value of a is to the
left of the absolute value of B on our
number line it is less than the absolute
value of B so this is not true all right
next statement absolute value of a is
less than the absolute value of C well
we already know that the absolute value
of a is the same value as C so what's
the absolute value of C well the
absolute value of a positive number is
just going to be that number so this
this point right over here is also the
absolute value of C so we see that the
absolute value of a is equal to the
absolute value of C it's not less than
so we are going to rock we're going to
mark that off we could have written
absolute value of a is equal to absolute
value of C that would have been true all
right last one
a is less than C well once again a is to
the left of C on the number line so that
is true because our number line is
increasing as we go from left to right
if one number is to the left of another
number it is less than the other number
so a is indeed less than C and we are
done